to get this ultra smooth flying shot
from 2021's one division you'll see that
the show's stunt team relied on a
complex wire setup wires in superhero
movies and shows aren't new but they've
gotten a lot more sophisticated since
the genre's reset in 2000's x-men but
you can really see just how realistic
hollywood flying scenes have become by
going all the way back to the
back 1950s many of superman's earliest
flying stunts were low tech to take off
from the ground actor george reeves
would jump off a springboard that was
either just off camera or hidden by
objects in the frame and for shots when
superman would land through a window he
would simply climb up a ladder and jump
down with a foam mattress to cushion his
falls but early hollywood stunt work was
not known for its safety standards
active flying scenes were filmed using
wires and during one production the
wires holding up george snapped this led
to the use of pans a low-tech but
game-changing solution george would lay
stomach down on the pan while the crew
moved him around using a large pole that
ran under his legs with his arms
stretched out it could look like the
actor was flying and because the pan was
molded for the actor's body the crew
could hide it under his costume to
really sell the myth of flying an actor
needs to actively use their core and
shoulders basically whatever your
shoulders whatever this this part of
your body is doing is telling the story
compare george reeves flying to
christopher reeves in 1978 superman
christopher was also laying flat but the
actor's experience as a glider helped
him hold his body in a more natural and
aerodynamic fashion
the filmmakers also wanted to emphasize
more movement on screen so for wider
full-body shots the crew experimented
with launching a mannequin out of a
cannon and even flying a remote
controlled superman doll but to get this
kind of shot it took vfx artist zorin
perisic and his pioneering zoptic
optical process this required a front
projected backdrop where a two-way
mirror is placed in front of the camera
lens the desired background is projected
and bounces off the mirror onto a beaded
screen all of that was put onto a moving
rig so the camera and projector could
move in sync zoram then added synced
zoom lenses to both the projector and
camera lens to make it look like
superman was flying towards the camera
even if the actors were motionless
zooming in couldn't solve one problem
though how to make superman's iconic
cape billow in the wind a wind machine
on its own wasn't powerful enough so the
special effects team made a remote
controlled rig with rods attached to it
to place on the actor's back hidden
under the cape the combination of the
rods moving up and down and the wind
machine made the cape flap as superman
soars over metropolis
these contraptions became outdated once
visual effects could place capes and
wings in post as you can see in these
behind the scenes shots of 2013's man of
steel henry cavill isn't wearing a cape
but wire rigging remains the primary
method of flying thanks to its
versatility the same method that created
superman and wonder woman's graceful
flight can also be used for a less than
graceful crash landing as seen here from
avengers infinity war
setups can get very complicated when
shots involve multiple characters in the
air at once like when wanda battles
agatha in one division to allow the
characters to circle and interact with
each other the team attached their wires
to a truss made out of an aluminum-like
material this supportive structure could
be bolted together quickly and into
nearly any configuration which was
useful for creating all types of flying
configurations here stunt rigger zack
henry locked the two stunt performers
wires in place the truss was moved
around in such a way that it looked like
the two characters were circling each
other we could fly at each other and
throw blasts and get those wide shots
where the wires are attached is just as
important as the wires and rigs
themselves take this shot of wanda
lifting yourself off the ground
according to cc who doubled for
elizabeth olsen this shot was made a
reality because of precisely where they
hooked the wires into her harness these
are known as pick points small but
strong loops in the harness where the
wires are attached those points can
change depending on the performer and
the type of action in this case cc was
attached at her hips directly to the
spreader bar i can move in between those
lines and find my moment of balance it
would allow me to stay in that
horizontal flight without swinging back
and giving away the illusion that it was
a wire for wanda to glide off the ground
at an angle cece had two lines attached
to her one to her back and the other to
her front pulling her up and forwards
simultaneously nearly impossible
coordination would be needed to make
sure these two actions happened at the
exact same time so the stunt team
attached the wires to computerized
winches programming in the speeds and
direction the more precise timing
created consistent movement for the
camera and for the actors you want it to
be the same for the actor every time so
that they can learn that rhythm and then
they can start performing it wire
rigging takes a lot of planning and
coordination this flying stunt from
wonder woman 1984 took almost 20 000
feet of wires to get right so sometimes
teams might turn to a simplified setup
like a tuning fork which provides
flexibility in choreography
according to vfx supervisor gary
brzenich the flying sequences and
maleficent mistress of evil benefited
from tuning forks which could stop start
and change direction on the spot the
performer is clamped in at their hips by
two prongs while stunt performers steer
them around
the fork is also useful for floating
shots but actors will still have to
focus on their legs if your chest is
doing something your legs are just kind
of dangling there it doesn't really look
like you're flying at all when it comes
to executing a perfect landing the stunt
team will switch up their methods to
allow both characters feet to land on
the ground like in this shot when the
stunt team used what's called a
parallelogram a performer stands on a
platform strapped in with just a belt
counterweight balancing moves it up and
down while the legs stay completely
still they can actually look like
they're floating while they're standing
on a little piece of platform
parallelograms are more comfortable than
wires and tuning forks but the actor's
form here is crucial not just for
selling the illusion but also for their
own safety you never want to have
straight legs when you hit the ground
you have to have your knees slightly
bent to receive the ground or else you
can really damage your knees and your
ankles for these rigs to work safely and
effectively both the performer and the
crew guiding them need to work in unison
which of course is prone to human error
that's where the robo moco arm might
come in
take this scene from black widow where
natasha and elena free fall before
safely parachuting to the ground a lot
of prep went into that sequence to
discover which part would be best to
have on the rope a milk arm versus which
part would be best to have in the wires
certain free falling and tumbling shots
involved repeating the same motion in a
straight path for these stunts an actor
was attached to the robomoco arm using
just two pick points the path was then
programmed in advance helpful for
repeating moves over and over for
different performers they don't have
much to do so they can just be in that
robo-mocha arm and letting it manipulate
them as they fall through the sky the
robotic arm can also work directly in
sync with a motion control camera
creating smoother and more continuous
flying shots this tool also proved
itself useful for tumbling through the
air in one continuous motion as shown
here in sherlock holmes a game of
shadows
sometimes you don't even need a real
person flying at all today's vfx is
capable of creating digital doubles from
scratch from the spider-man movies to
man of steel digital doubles can perform
gravity-defying moves but flying scenes
are most convincing when they're all
these techniques at once even the most
cg heavy flying would be nothing without
the pans and wires that made early
superman fly in fact you can see michael
shannon lying on one of those pans and
man of steel it's really a team effort
when it comes to flying in superhero
magic lands all departments are involved
in making that look amazing to have the
reference of the real thing makes it
that much better and it is real then it
it does read to the audience that that
is plausible that that is actually
something that could happen that could
be done because we did do it